good evening ladies and gentlemen and
thank you for coming along my day job is
public policy editor of the economist
but like you tonight i'm here to listen
and learn from a very fascinating debate
i'm sure you'll agree a natural gas
revolution hot air or a dose of sanity
or possibly a bit of both
but first of all i would like to
introduce our first speaker tonight
that's vim thomas who's chief energy
advisor at shell
gas will be a backbone of sustainable
energy systems of the future why do i
say that well gas is abundant and
affordable etc but
if you want to have more and more
renewable intermittent renewables in
your system you need a kind of backbone
and flexible
backup source which can actually
take up the flexibility very cost
efficiently now we have done a lot of
scenario exercises
and every time right you see that
actually gas is a very good
cost-effective way to actually deal with
intermittency but also we see some kind
of natural saturation points in certain
sectors of renewables so when people say
100 renewables for everything is
possible i doubt it and certainly not in
the next 20 years joining us now
professor mike stevenson who is head of
science and energy at the british
geological survey look at this a
somerset expert reckons that if you do
shale gas in the mendips it will turn
into a volcano and people believe it
you know
they p people believe it and and this is
the quality of the debate that's out
there
you know i'm not saying that shale gas
is the answer i'm not saying that ccs is
i'm not saying that double global
nuclear power either is and
but it's it's a problem because if you
if you want to do these things they're
all geological and the public
you know have many many questions about
the feasibility and the safety of it
science needs to take a stronger role in
this particularly independent science to
assess the risk and to do it publicly
and transparently and openly very good
time to hear from our next speaker which
is dr shamil yanukov who is research
fellow at the oxford institute sorry of
energy studies does gas help of hindu
making the world a safer place obviously
the increased
availability of
supplies
and increased diversity of sources is a
very important factor
and because gas producers are being
becoming more responsible being being
more responsible by new this new
competition
and
producing consumer relations as a result
uh mutual dependence
uh will create greater stability
at the same time some uh
transnational pipelines such as
turkmenistan afghanistan pakistan india
pipeline could promote as well
integration and stability in those
regions but
one final point
is that
the battles will continue but there will
be battles based on based around markets
roots regulation technology competitive
advantage in prices and environment
and domestic politics will play the key
role in that particularly in the united
states and russia thank you thank you
very much
i'm going to welcome to the stage with
me dr pierre noel who is senior research
associate and director of energy policy
forum at the university of cambridge
specializing in oil and gas markets and
industry and david how lord howe was an
adviser to the foreign secretary on
energy security and a former minister of
state at the foreign office with
responsibility for international
energy issues the green agenda if
pressed
incompetently in political terms with
the wrong compelling messages uh imposed
on people in the wrong ways will
actually delay the green revolution the
and we've just had a perfect example
here that people are saying oh we must
be very careful about gas expansion and
we don't shale gas in america's fine but
uh we don't want to see too much
encouragement here what is the net
effect of that the net effect is that
american coal is pouring into europe
we're burning more coal here in this
country europe's coal as a whole is
increasing the actual and germans are
planning new coal-fired
stations with and um co2 while informing
falling to america to the 20 20-year
level
lowest level
uh and the fallen 14 in the last two
years
and the per capita emissions has fallen
dramatically
whatever we do on climate change we have
to do it cost effectively we have to
start with the cheapest carbon emission
reductions that we can get
currently we're starting with the most
expensive ones offshore winds
is a typical example
solar panels is another typical india
the cost of them is falling quite
quickly we have to be honest but still
very very high
um
that's the first message do it do it
cost effectively the the only way that i
know about to do that is simply to tax
cover
right at the highest level that the
political process will allow
which we may not be very very high
but hopefully we'll be higher than what
we currently have thanks to all of our
speakers and of course to intelligence
squared and shell for hosting this event
which i've certainly enjoyed very much
and hope you have